different phenomena first of them is
connected to the fact that after the
communist rule collapsed it was possible
to introduce openly the new school of
political thinking as regards a Polish
Eastern policy that was developed in
Polish immigration by cultura monthly
and yes we give Raj its editor-in-chief
during first 40 years after World War
two what generates established in the
immigration started to be a kind of
almost official almost almost natural
element of Polish self perception as
regards polished and in visa the Ukraine
that Poland should destroy historical
barriers between Poland and Ukraine and
that polished historical discourse
should become much more open to
Ukrainian subjects to Ukrainian polish
Ukrainian historical quarrels in order
to to make them only only a matter of
past and not spoiling any more political
relations between Poland and regenerated
Ukraine the second element that
influenced this new this new narrative
of Polish Ukrainian relations of the
interwar period is connected to an
overall change of geopolitical position
of tolerant Poland while joining Nate
and European Union at the same time
tries to keep it open to the east maybe
not always comes consequently and it
might be criticized from different
angles but nevertheless official polish
position in this respect is to keep both
NATO and aunt European Union opened to
Ukraine as the most important country on
polish eastern border so this made a
kind of new political context for Polish
historical thinking on very difficult
polish ukrainian relations between what
would one and World War two but there
was also another new or relatively new
phenomenon a new wave if I could say so
of Polish history ography this one a
much lower and less clear than the first
one I described in the beginning this
second wave of polish historiography
concerning polish ukrainian relations of
the period that we are discussing now is
connected with the fact that for the
first time after the collapse of the
communist regime it was possible to
speak openly about some subjects that i
could spoil socialist brotherhood of
nations namely about the most cruel the
most difficult blank pages in a Polish
Ukrainian history so in this second new
so to speak wave of Polish
historiography we can observe however
not very numerous resurgence of elements
of resurgence of actually pre-war
nationalist
or near nationalist vision of Ukraine as
the most important enemy of Poland in
the East that that is responsible for
the cruelest the most cruel conspiracies
first during the interwar period and
revolts against polish land roads during
World War one that prepared finally the
massacres in World War two as I told
this wave of publications is relatively
low and in comparison with the first one
influenced by cultura by the adroit and
by Polish official Eastern policy but it
exists and it would be unfair to say
that that we don't have in our if I can
call it historiography such phenomena as
professor at bat truce with his fiercely
anti Ukrainian books on especially a
organization of Ukrainian nationalists
or about metropolis and research is key
and we absorb such phenomena